rage pour la sortie de mes années
collège pour la plupart des élèves de ma
classe
c'est une sortie comme les autres ce
jour là j'ai 11 ans et je visite la
brasserie de sochaux je sens cette odeur
chaude envoûtante g elle nous avait
grillé une odeur qui me rappelle le
petit déjeuner c'est l'odeur du malt
chaud je vois secure rutilante immense
on dirait des cathédrales de cuivre je
me sens tout petit à côté
dans une autre salle je vois des cuves
de fermentation ouverte alignées les
unes contre les autres c'est que vous
verte je me penche et je vois la
fermentation sous mes yeux je vois les
hôtes mousse
on dirait des choux fleurs qui gigote et
cette odeur cette odeur si forte si la
cre acide vraiment très très très
particulière c'est l'odeur de la
fermentation
même maintenant vous connaissez ma
madeleine de proust
ces deux odeurs le malt chaud la
fermentation
ce sont deux odeurs que je retrouve à
chaque fois que je rentre dans une
brasserie alors
certains rentrer dans les ordres et bien
moi j'ai décidé de rentrer en bref free
eh bien oui et à travers ce choix j'ai
je visite je voyage dans le monde entier
pour visiter des brasseries qu'elle soit
artisanale nationale minuscules ou
planétaires dans chaque brasserie je
retrouve ces deux odeurs je suis rentré
brasserie la bière c'est mon univers
c'est vraiment là où je me sens bien la
bière non pas la bière non non non les
bières les bières les bières la bière au
bois de la bière on déguste des pierres
alors si si je vous pose maintenant une
question si je vous dis le mot bière
qu'est ce que vous allez me répondre je
vais vous je vais entendre je vais
entendre des mots comme boisson d'hommes
ventre à bière vides à bière boisson bof
pizza foot la bière ça ballone la bière
ça fait grossir la bière c'est anr
j'aime pas la bière
celle là je n'entends tout le temps
et vous alors allez-y vous posez moi la
question
allez je vais vous dire les mots d'un
liquide femmes brasseuse ds origines de
la civilisation fécondation boissons
nourricière mois sans renouveau nature
gilgamesh mésopotamie egypte grèce
hildegarde de bingen moines trappistes
magique alchimique mystérieuse
multimillénaire alors je vais vous
raconter l'histoire des bières et jose
est sûr que vous allez remonter avec moi
le temps ça va nous vous allez ça va
nous remonter très très loin au début du
néolithique les premières céréales
apparaissent ces de l'orge
elles seraient elles sont cueillies
elles sont cultivées les premiers pains
liquide nes
c'est le début de l'agriculture c'est le
début de notre civilisation
c'est l'histoire des bières en
mésopotamie
nous allons des chiffres est sur les
tablettes d'argile l'histoire les
recettes de cette boisson que l'on
appelle sicard eus qui va du pain d'orge
émietté dans du jus de dates à cette
boisson parfumé de teint de genièvre de
cumin et de genévrier en egypte il y à
une brasserie même dans le temple de
néfertiti parce que la bière et boissons
de frande toujours en egypte
nous rencontrons cette femme brasseuse
qui brasse à pleines mains
symboliquement comme elle pétrir le pain
les femmes sont les premiers brasseurs
les femmes font le pain elles font la
bière à la maison
au moyen âge les monastères apparaissent
les brasseries monacale se développent
et au premier au premier mois de
brasseurs à saint denis
charles le chauve un son en 862 nous
sommes en 862 offre des boisseaux
d'épeautre pour faire de la cervoise
nous allons en bourgogne a6 tôt vous
connaissez si tôt les moines cisterciens
qui habite
il observe la règle de saint benoît
alors cette règle certains moines n'ont
pas trouvé assez dur ils le veulent les
règles plus strictes
donc ils s'en vont s'établir à trappes
tapis ti village de normandie
il y fonde l'abbaye de la trappe
eh bien oui les bières trappistes sont
nés en france contrairement à ce qu'on
peut croire et c'est à la révolution un
peu plus tard que ces mêmes moines de la
trappe sont obligés de s'exiler et où
vont-ils a les intéristes cela entre
autres dans un petit village en belgique
avec mal peut-être le connaissez vous il
dit fonde l'abbaye de westmalle et bien
c'est assez curieux tout de même que les
très très fameuse bière trappiste de
l'abbaye de westmalle soit né à cause de
la révolution française
une femme précieuse abaisse la plus
fameuse d'entre elles s'appellent
hildegarde de bingen cette femme elle
fonde son abbaye en 147 en allemagne et
les médecins en plus d'être brasseuse
des abbesses et elle connaît les plantes
elle est très très grande connaissance
des plantes et elle découvre entre
autres dans ses recherches sur les
plantes que le houblon à cette
caractéristique incroyable de conserver
les aliments
donc c'est très utile pour la bière
parce que la guerre ça a du mal à
conserver jusque là petit à petit le
houblon rentrer dans la cervoise qui a
la bave n'a pas de doublons et c'est
ainsi que le houblon ce généraliste dans
la bière et le mot bière apparaît
d'ailleurs au xvème siècle au moment où
le houblon généralisée nous allons en
angleterre et nous allons rencontrer des
femmes brasseuse fameuse ce sont les and
wives leurs bières sont si fameuse qu'on
se précipite chez elle pour aller
dégoûté leurs maisons deviennent des
papes des créances qui vont préfigurer
les futurs pub
retournons un petit peu au grain d'orge
au printemps on va semer l'orge
en été on le récolte en automne l'orgie
se repose
c'est la dormance de l'orge et en hiver
eh bien nous sommes là en octobre et
c'est le temps de brasser alors pourquoi
et bien parce que pour faire de la bière
il faut du froid on était ce difficile
de faire de la bière
parce que les brassens infecte tourner
en hiver bras ce qui veut en été bras ce
qui peut il ya même un arrêté royal en
1709 qui interdit de brasser avant le
1er octobre
c'est ainsi que les brasseurs de tout
temps ont calé leur calendrier
brassicole sur les calendriers des
saisons tout simplement et c'est ainsi
que la madame anne la nature au père
la magie de la nature au père et le
cycle de l'orge et le cycle de la bière
et le cycle de l'orge et le cycle de la
bière et jusqu'au 19ème siècle enfin fin
19ème siècle les graffeurs respecte ce
rythme des saisons alors évidemment bien
sûr maintenant ils sont plus du tout
obligé de suivre ce rythme des saisons
le front industriel a été inventé à la
fin du 19e et bien tous n'ont pas tous
parce qu'il ya quelques brasseur qui
continuent à respecter ce rythme de la
nature
nous allons nous allons à bruxelles je
vous emmène à bruxelles dans une de ces
mythique brasserie vous savez qui
s'appelle cantillon là sous la toiture
dans le grand bac rouge de cuivre c'est
la nature qui féconde le moof durant une
nuit pendant la saison d'hiver
et comme le dit jean-pierre avant de
rome le brasseur qui s'est battu
vraiment battus pour que cette ce rythme
des saisons soit conservée et il a eu
bien raison et bien jean-pierre vendredi
- bras fort mondialement connu je ne
suis rien à côté de la nature parce que
c'est elle qui fait tout
je pense messieurs dans la salle je suis
sûr que évidemment vous ne comprenez pas
grand choses quelquefois aux femmes j'ai
entendu souvent dire ce genre de phrase
eh bien rassurez-vous le brasseur il est
comme vous mais en plus il ne comprend
pas nehar pas de tout ce qui se passe
dans sa cuve pendant des millénaires et
des siècles c'est absolument incroyable
ce qui se passe cette transformation
entre le grain d'orge et la boisson qui
en entier en sort c'est magique c'est
tellement magique que dans la salle de
brassage le symbole de la bière c'est
l'étoile des brasseurs et cette étoile
elle est formée des quatre symboles
alchimique des quatre éléments qui
constituent la fabrication de la bière
c'est l'eau la terre l'air et le feu
et y'a aucun brasseur aucun jusqu'à la
fin du 19e siècle qui aurait laissé sa
salle de brassage
sans la protection de cette étoile cette
boisson magique
elle est également mystérieuse dans la
dans le premier récit de l'humanité
l'épopée de gilgamesh une fois qu'il est
arrivé au bout de la terre gilgamesh
place à la déesse de la fermentation qui
lui offre à boire de l'eau claire et
cette boisson elle est faite dans un
chaudron le changerons sept objets
rituels présent absolument dans toutes
les mythologies dans toutes les cultures
le saudron d'abondance le chaudron
d'immortalité le chaudron magique
cette boisson mystérieuse et magique
elle est également nourricière la
cervoise vous connaissez la cervoise oui
et bien la cervoise ça veut dire force
des céréales parce que ses rêves c'est
la déesse des céréales et vi en latin
c'est la force de cette boisson
nourricière
c'est l'aliment de base pendant des
millénaires c'est la boisson que les
moines de nos pèlerins pour les
rassasier
c'est la boisson que les marins au long
cours en portent sur leurs bateaux pour
lutter contre le scorbut et la pellagre
c'est la boisson qui favorise
l'allaitement
oui absolument
c'est une croyance populaire mais je
vous êtes sûr qu'elle ait démontré
scientifiquement on en trouve d'ailleurs
dans les pharmacies jusque dans les
annales dents jusque dans les années 50
un des bières de nourrice et bien cette
boisson nourricière est légalement elle
fait penser à un objet symbole même de
la vie le à l'usure le feu sur un objet
unique incroyable cet objet renferme le
secret de la bière en devenir
la mesure la levure vous avez tous celui
les maîtres de l'orge la mesure c'est
l'âme de la bière c'est la signature du
brasseur il ya des brasseurs qui le
disent très souvent très mal vu l'a pas
vu le travail ce matin mal vivre c'est
comme ma femme c'est comme un compagne
une maîtresse elle est assez capricieuse
mal durant ce moment c'est parce qu'elle
a un truc mais fleury j'y peux rien jp
rien du tout c'est comme ça ma levure
j'y peux rien elle fait ce qu'elle veut
alors elle travaille beaucoup et puis
après ils se reposent
norman
et oui le grain d'orge la levure la
levure et le grain d'orge dit hausse en
grec le grain d'orge le vin d'orge en
egypte c'est le sictom l'asie tôt logis
la cytologie c'est la science c'est
l'étude
les bières c'est un mot qu'on utilise
surtout en belgique
alors vous savez maintenant ce que je
suis je pense vous avez deviné
psychologue expert bière qu'est ce que
c'est c'est d'abord transmettre la
connaissance des bières à travers les
dégustations et c'est aussi raconter les
histoires des hommes et des femmes qui
brasse pour les faire partager pour les
faire comprendre pourquoi ils brassent
ses bières là alors dans le sud de
l'aveyron sur les contreforts du larzac
je vous vous dis d'aller rencontrer
baptiste c'est le fermier brasseur il va
vous expliquer comment il cultive ses
céréales comment ils malte céréales
comment il les fait griller comment il
fait pousser ses houblon dans le jura
c'est bruno bruno et les restaurateurs
et il est devenu brasseur et il va vous
faire goûter son impérial staut qui fait
vieillir trois ans dans des fûts de vin
de paille au bord du lac d'annecy c'est
stéphanie la brasseuse des montagnes qui
va vous parler de sa blonde blanche
noire et qui va vous initier au brassage
en belgique pas très loin de liège dans
l'abbaye de valdieu et bien c'est une
jeune femme qui est brasseuse au coeur
de cette abbaye absolument magique et
virginie elle va vous dévoiler les
secrets de sa triple alors oui j'entends
souvent je n'aime pas la bière
je n'aime pas la bière alors vous
n'aimez vous n'aimez pas quel goût
exactement intel amertume que vous
n'aimez pas donné mais pas la mer
concernés à vous n'aimez pas causé la
mer alors je vais vous accompagnez je
vais vous proposer des bières qui sont
fruités qui sont acidulées qui sont
sûres est qu'ils sont épicés chocolatées
floral vous n'aimez pas les bières
brunes ou les pierres blanches où les
bières blondes à vous n'aimez pas non
plus les bière rousse
non parce que ça c'est des phrases que
j'entends tout le temps et ça n'a pas
tellement de sens à mon avis parce que
vous savez une couleur et bien ce n'est
pas un goût alors à ce moment là je vais
vous proposer par exemple des bières
brunes
je vous choisir une via brune et pis
c'est une guerre brune chocolatées une
via brune fruité floral une bière brune
chocolatées cacaotées en début d'année
lié j'ai cette jeune femme qui me qui me
dit j'aime pas la bière brune à bien son
coup de coeur en fin d'atelier c'est la
bière la plus noire la plus torréfié au
goût de café et sur ce festival
cette autre jeune femme me dit je n'aime
pas la bière alors qu'est ce que je vais
bien pouvoir lui faire goûter pour
qu'elle aime la bière ce nectar de might
de remuer de muscade raisin de miel et
de safran c'est une
c'est un bijou un bijou mais la
demoiselle ne dédaignent
c'est ce lambic acidulées sur est en
diable la demoiselle adore
une autre proposition une bière brune
vanille et chocolat thé complexe elle
adore à nouveau je pense que certains
parmi vous peut-être pense ne pas aimer
la bière je suis sûr c'est certainement
parce que vous n'avez pas encore
rencontré les bières que vous pourrez
aimé ce regard neuf que vous posez sur
les bières et bien c'est mon moteur mon
ressort
merci à tous les brasseurs et les
précieuses qui créent tous les jours des
nouvelles bières la bière est en
perpétuelle renaissance c'est la boisson
la plus moderne qui soit et en même
temps la plus ancienne de l'humanité
alors maintenant je vais partir à une
dégustation vous venez je vous emmène à
l'est suivez-moi